marc sylvestre bonjour alors emmanuel
macron se pose en sauveur de la filière
automobile avec une ambition restaurer
l'image et protéger la souveraineté le
tout pour 8 milliards d'euros est ce que
ça peut marcher selon vous il faut
espérer que cela marche parce que ça
quand même
ça représente pas mal d'argent les
milliards dont 5 milliards de prêts à
renault dont je rappelle que l'état à
une participation importante enfin chez
renault c'est donc une entreprise
j'avais dit rond national
donc l'état a tout intérêt à tout faire
pour essayer de sauver renault en
réalité à deux opérations dans tout ça
il ya une opération économique très
court terme puis à une opération
politique personnelle du président alors
l'opération économique
elle consiste à tout faire pour écouler
les invendus on l'a vu on a dit des
constructeurs automobiles n'ont pas
vendu une seule voiture en deux mois et
demi il ya 400 milles de véhicules sur
les parkings chez les concessionnaires
le marché s'est effondré de 80% va donc
tout faire pour inciter les
consommateurs à acheter une nouvelle
voiture des consommateurs qui ont des
paroles des consommateurs qui ont de
l'argent et qui pourrait donc évidemment
changer de voiture les primes sont très
importantes
elles vont en gros en moyenne de 3000 à
8000 euros on peut même aller en
cumulant tôt jusqu'à 12000 euros donc ça
revient à brader le prix des voitures on
va moduler bien sûr en fonction de ce
qu'on achète soit électrique soit de
l'hybride soit du thermique on va
principalement acheté du thermique parce
que le parc automobile français est à
95% en termes et que l'électrique n'a
pas encore tellement la coque il a pas
mal de défauts le consommateur n'est pas
enthousiaste sur sur l'électrique
et puis les ventes se feront
principalement sur des voitures
classiques fabriqués en france
quand vous dites qu'il ya une opération
politique vous pensez à quoi exactement
mais écoutez je vois un président de la
république qui reconstruit son image de
sauveur de l'industrie
la semaine dernière ils étaient d'ordre
dans l'industrie touristique
or il pour laquelle il y là il a
débloqué à peu près une dizaine de
milliards la semaine prochaine il ira au
chevet de l'aéronautique c'est à dire
des transporteurs à air france airbus
l'automobile c'est une vache sacrée en
france c'est une vache sacrée c'est une
composante de la souveraineté
pas question de laisser tomber renault
d'autant que renault à partir quand même
un peu à des parts dans les mains il
faut pas laisser tomber parce que les
japonais
il nous guette ils ont déjà déboulonner
carlos ghosn pas question d'abandonner
non plus un million d'emplois dans cette
filière en ce moment où on ne repart que
de relocalisation est-ce que l'étape de
mende est garanti de préserver l'emploi
oui alors le président comme le ministre
de l'économie d'ailleurs ono le maire
qui assure un peu le service après-vente
de l'opération ils en ont beaucoup parlé
mais en réalité ça va dépendre
essentiellement des constructeurs le
plan va avoir un effet à très court
terme
dans l'immédiat on sauve la trésorerie
des constructeurs mais on pourra pas
maintenir des primes indéfiniment il
faudra donc que les constructeurs assume
la réalité du marché et la réalité du
marché
elle est essentiellement dans les pays
émergents il faut donc continuer
d'exporter il faut donc continuer de
fabriquer des voitures dans des pays qui
nous les achète ses voitures donc on ne
peut pas parler de relocalisation je
pense pas qu'il y en ait beaucoup et lé
constructeur n'aurait aucun intérêt à
relocaliser des fabrications sont
actuellement fait en turquie en
slovaquie ou en chine n'ont en revanche
ce que l'on peut faire et ce à quoi les
constructeurs se sont engagés c'est à
localiser et à recréer des industries à
haute valeur ajoutée en france qui vont
composer l'automobile de demain
c'est-à-dire tout ce qui concerne
électronique la connectique et surtout
surtout la fabrication des batteries
c'est la france comme l'allemagne ont
une grande tradition automobile les
anglais ont perdu complètement leur
industrie automobile mais les français
et allemands ont conservé la leur et
pour la conserver ils doivent
obligatoirement semaine dans le haut de
gamme et se met dans la modernité
parce que le marché la gamme le marché
de masse il n'est plus en france
jean marc sylvestre un journaliste et
éditorialiste art économique merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions